This is a straightforward implementation of the forward Euler method.
This x at the initial step is actually 2D vector. S is the y.
The result will again be a 2D vector with those two values for the two trajectories in it.
The resulting diagram may need some explanation.
We see the distance between the x values of the two trajectories over the course of time.
Initially, they are really close--10^-14.
And then they grow and eventually become macroscopic--10^100.
The important thing to be seeing is this linear slop.
But actually it's not linear.
We are working with a logarithmic vertical axis,
which means that the distance grows in exponential fashion.
It takes about 30 units of time to increase the error from 10^-14 to 10^-4.
These are 10 orders of magnitude, a factor of 1 to 10 billion.
This leads to the following conclusion:
whenever there is an uncertainty about the initial conditions--
however tiny--the effect of this uncertainty will quickly grow to a visible size.
So, even those the system is deterministic,
once we have fixed the initial conditions, everything is determined--
even though that is the case, it's behavior looks random.
This sensitive dependence on initial conditions is the hallmark of deterministic chaos.
That is to be expected.
Every system, which includes convection, also inherits this aspect.
If somewhere a butterfly flaps its wings, some days or months afterward
this is going to change the weather at some remote location on the earth.